oh so tempting just invite the strong
this is a hip you never find this in
America at Starbucks at least what's up
guys I'm cute and today I'm gonna be
showing you the u.s. versus Japan
Starbucks imma start with this one I
think this is the peppermint mocha I'm
not sure how I feel about that like
peppermint with anything is not a good
thing to me my beer oh okay let's see
see here's the thing I feel like the
specialty drinks from places aren't
always a little weird like pumpkin spice
peppermint mocha like this is a little
strange to me I feel like I'm drinking a
mint and that's not a good thing
I mean it's tasty I guess Lilly's like a
really funny excitation my mother I'm
not really feeling this is already like
a strike against the u.s. already like I
feel like Japan I feel like Tokyo
wouldn't do that they're not gonna put
like weird mints in your drink I don't
know I don't know but this is definitely
strike for the US this is weird I don't
really like this I'm drinking it though
so that's that's something all right so
I officially made it to your PIN my
right now kind of quiet let's do it with
some much of white chocolate I'd say
well pretty sure it's basically just
like green tea and the white chocolate
it's fire has a kind of like a tea
flavor like the green tea might say
wasn't that good businessman like matcha
is like a huge thing enough like now is
spread everywhere let's see what this
one is a green tea latte that actually
sounds pretty delicious
oh that looks disgusting tastes all
right
just don't open the top don't open the
can this seems like something that you
could get in Japan I thought they'd have
like a green mint green something Oh
like matcha like matcha flavor green tea
latte like to be honest it looks a
little funny it tastes okay but it
smells like it smells like the sea not
bad this with the Santa boots santa
boobs Frappuccino that's pretty tight
like when the u.s. thinks of Christmas
they put peppermint Japan thinks of
cookies and chocolate that makes more
sense
so this also has potato chips in it in
chocolate balls this is crazy
this is good though and so tempting just
to bite the straw this gets a thumbs up
this is way more Christmassy than
peppermint peppermint drinks are
disgusting I'm sorry all right let's
dive into this thing we're in LA right
now and this is like a la thing I feel
like everybody drinks us I don't know
what the hell it is it's called a dragon
drink and I'm guessing it's dragon fruit
in here I was like little chunks of in
there let's see that's pretty good
I see the hype no damn this is a hit
this is good for several reasons this is
good because it tastes good it looks
good and imagine the Instagram photo you
can take with this ping tree like
hashtag is dragon drink has to be a
thing alright so apparently it's a lot
of in here it's like mango passionfruit
love strawberries the ingredients go
deep man this is good but this is a
smash like us just finally got on the
board this is a shrimp and broccoli
sandwich oh so true
broccoli inside garlic wait outside it
smells so good
definitely unique like you would never
find this in America I Starbucks at
least I mean I'm not surprised that's
good but like is really good I'll go to
in the u.s. is a sausage cheddar biscuit
I mean I can't say I picked this over it
everytime Kadesh shrimp it is garlic as
I smell it's one a daily basis I
probably get a sausage biscuit if I want
something that's good and tasty let's
give her something over here I know
about this this is an iced lemon love
this inspired like I order this every
week at least three to four times cause
it's so good
like the icing on top it's honestly too
much but it's just a perfect amount for
me I feel like Tokyo isn't gonna have
anything like this
what would Tokyo have for dessert a
little mochi balls or something like
that you know this is American this is
some American bull you and the board
this is also a half-court shot swish the
u.s. is coming back you were sick you
were sick this is called strawberry
discovery looks pretty like sticky and
messy which isn't a Miami bug pink
strawberry Oh like my favorite I need a
fork for it is it really good is amazing
I'm no food expert but the inside seems
like moves out sides like Jim Oh know
what that is but just do it
savage model
[Music]
a double smoked bacon sandwich
this looks pretty appealing to me like
alibi this the bacon looks pretty solid
the cheese look pretty hard
oh I won't take that against them listen
here this is good this is just like a
classic American breakfast you know I'm
saying you got some eggs and got some
bacon we got some carbs and look at the
top of that bad boy see ya as beautiful
imagine an Instagram photo from the top
you know with the coffee right there
boom minimum 50 lux you know depending
on your page no Frodo this is some
classic American I'm for it
this is the American waffle this was
fire I thought it was kind of funny in
America we'd Belgian waffles were my own
are so good here they are they're in my
office something else let me see how it
tastes it's okay like awful to give a
nap butter and syrup on it it'll be good
right now it's just plain I guess from
comparing it to like us desserts
yeah why this is solid like it's
definitely up there for sure the parrot
is like a waffle period is it whatever
this is the iced salted caramel mocha
again just sounds like so typical like
la bullsh
what's a macchiato that's my question
what the hell is a macchiato that's what
I want I feel like my boss's boss orders
macchiatos you know I'm saying oh it's a
lot that's really sweet but good like
caramel isn't my go-to thing to eat or
drink it's like sweet sweet and salty
yeah salted caramel yeah this is really
good here like a sweet tooth or just
want something that tastes like a
dessert for breakfast but yeah right now
this is a lot for me but I flee this is
like universal like I'm sure they have
these in every Starbucks around the
world this is just classic iced coffee
this is nutty white chocolate
whoa this is amazing
so as white chocolate obviously they're
also like gold coated from roasted
almonds which is like pretty tight this
is good for a sugar rush this is like
right now it's Christmastime Japan
understands Christmas they understand
how to do Christmas flavored drinks and
themed stuff the u.s. takes it
immediately to peppermints like is that
all you got this is fire chestnuts
roasting on an open fire white chocolate
mocha this sounds really good everybody
loves white chocolate let's look at it
though just smells like the last thing
let's see okay I get it okay so the
white chocolate mocha is good and it
tastes like the other one I had before
but a lot more subtle this is for
somebody who wants like a little taste
of something but not like too much this
is it so this is good this is like me
this is what I want like it's sweet but
not like super sweet
you know I first taste I'm like this
taste like anything which is like for
some people a good thing so this is this
is solid and it sounds like fancy you
know under a you know white chocolate
mocha so we got a cinnamon roll I'm not
sure I was gonna taste but they made
sure to make you look amazing I mean
sorry like if you don't have a huge
sweet tooth this is for you
I like mine's to have a hole watch I
soon to be super sweet this was like
super light which isn't bad but it
depends on like your preference
this song is dude but I think it needs
like a side of icing no bad dog
like I keep saying right now this isn't
a good pair of Justice is this burst of
the US this would be the top thing I'm
guessing this is a cake pop this is what
I'm about
I love cupcakes I like cake in general
and this is the perfect size I'll get
like two of these and be good for today
there's real cute again like come on now
cuz some I say cancer I vote over me
anybody
Raj no but this would be a good eyes
Instagram photo that's all I'm saying
alright let's see how it tastes though
looks can be deceiving
looks might have been to see this kind
of nasty
maybe nasty isn't runway this is like
not what I thought was gonna be well it
looked good and that's what them
Instagram floda would be lit 75 likes
many more
oh yeah it's like it's okay it looks a
lot better than the taste the outer part
I'm not sure what I thought I was gonna
taste like but it didn't taste like that
like it should taste like strawberry
right and it does not remember this bar
again I feel like they made sure to make
it a little fire
it's very mediocre so basically to me
it's just like a graham cracker
cheesecake to like cream cheese and then
know that there's no in my favorite
thing I asked so far but it's pretty
good and I'll say it again
we're comparing this like blow from the
blow with the US and this would again be
somewhere up top
my tea was to me only have an iced lemon
cake pick up option he'll option that's
pretty good if I go back to Starbucks in
Japan that's something I can definitely
get for sure
well I'm fully that will go well with
some coffee Starbucks us I'm not mad at
what I have we have some highlights the
pink drink fire the lemon loaf fire this
classic
and it drinks I mean I would say this is
pretty good the white mocha the green
tea was a little weird but this was also
good so I mean overall I will be had
this is a pretty good like you know
pretty to mix us up all right that was
it
you finish it up after trying everything
in u.s. compared to everything in Japan
I have to say that Japan was a sort of
like you the drinks are better the food
better pretty much all around Starbucks
in Japan Wanda they understand Christmas
they got way more desserts way more food
like clearly Starbucks is a thing here
you know I'm actually like when you go
to Starbucks I like a to him yeah
Japan was this one u.s. Starbucks type
of game
[Music]